[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
cents troisième jour de guerre en
ukraine les affrontements font rage dans
le donbass après des avancées la
situation s'est aggravée pour l'armée
ukrainienne à ses rivaux donetsk sous
bombardement intensif des forces russes
dans le même temps une visite de sergueï
lavrov en serbie a dû être annulé ce
matin trois pays européens ont fermé
leur espace aérien à l'avion du chef de
la diplomatie russe une mesure jugée
scandaleuse par le kremlin ce week end
la dîmière poutine a déclaré que la
russie viserait de nouvelles cibles si
l'occident fournissait à l'ukraine des
missiles à longue portée cette gare en
ukraine est elle devenue une guerre
d'usure quelle est la résistance
ukrainienne dans le donbass qu'en est il
des crimes de guerre perpétrés par
l'armée russe que veut dire emmanuel
macron quand il affirme qu'il ne faut
pas humilier vladimir poutine ukraine la
guerre d'usure on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés anastasia chapeau china bonsoir
vous êtes maître de conférences en
géopolitique à sciences po spécialiste
des relations europe russie et
présidente du think tank easton sur
creuse bienvenue à vous en face de vous
cyril payen grand reporter à france 24
bonsoir cyril vous venez tout juste
d'ukraine justement et vous allez nous
raconter un peu quelle est la situation
sur le terrain bienvenue à vous dans le
débat jean de gliniasty bonsoir
directeur de recherche à l'iris ancien
consul général de france en russie
plusieurs livres bien sûr à votre actif
et le dernier la russie 2 points à
nouvel échiquier et c'est aux éditions
eyrolles avec nous également adrien des
heures adrien des avants soir vous êtes
rédacteur à la revue conflit hauteur de
la france atlantiste ou le naufrage de
la diplomatie bienvenue à vous
volodymyr hélas qui je vous le disais il
est allé au front il est allé au front
dans le bon bah sur ledit meireles qui
c'était une visite surprise ce week-end
on les écoute
je suis fier de tout ce que j'ai
rencontré de tous ceux à qui j'ai serré
la main de tous ceux avec qui j'ai
établi un lien et à qui j'ai exprimé mon
soutien
nous avons apporté quelque chose pour
l'armée je ne m'étendrai pas là-dessus
mais il ya quelque chose que nous vous
avons rapporté c'est important
nous vous avons rapporté la confiance
anastasia chapeau china est ce que
pourquoi est ce que vous le dis merci à
ce qui tout d'un coup a fait cette
visite surprise dans le bon basse c'est
pour redonner de redonner du courage en
fait aux troupes ukrainienne il était
donc allez chiche hanks je pense que
déjà pour donner le courage aussi pour
montrer que l'état est
le chef de forces armées dont lui-même
se
préoccupent de leur destin on a vu à
quand même pour moi c'est une visite qui
se fait justement par la suite de ce
qu'on a vu passer un mario paul ou a
donc l'ukraine en pensez et le
gouvernement craignant pensez avoir
négocié a donc
la laisser sortir du coût de plus de
2000 soldats à eux craignant notamment y
compris donc des combattants d'azov de
l'usiné originale de talent mais ensuite
qu'ils ont été rapportés du coup sur les
territoires contrôlés par la russie et
leur destin et bien sûr on n'est pas
connue ces soldats là pendant nombreuses
interviews avec des journalistes
ukrainiens et alors et aussi d'autres
journalistes pendant le bombardement ou
encore ils ont affirmé que leurs pires
assentiment c'était le sentiment d'être
abandonnés et parce que le sol à moyen
de pour eux pour sortir ça ne pouvait
plus sortir eux-mêmes du tout mais
c'était vraiment que les forces massives
de la migraine arrive et c'est une
libération ce qui était vraiment très
très lourd et les décisions des fêtes de
ne pas le faire plutôt passé vers une
négociation qui ont donc du coup pour
l'instant échoué peut-être en échange
aura lieu plus tard et pour moi cette
visite là et se place dans cette
consultation contexte pour justement
parce que la stratégie leur dit je ne
vous abandonne pas oui d'un encerclement
à plusieurs endroits c'est la stratégie
que les russes ont pratiqué beaucoup de
fois et ça c'est peut être là même
destin peut être
présenté aux un combattant ukrainien et
à l'armée ukrainienne à plusieurs autres
endroits y compris c'est leur donner
cyril losc effectivement c'est important
quel est le moral des troupes sur place
vous qui en revenait justement vous avez
beaucoup 12 étiez avec des ukrainiens
bah écoutez ça a changé
beaucoup sur la réalité du terrain
notamment dans la partie ouest puisque
moi c'est mon deuxième séjour est
effectivement les un sentiment un peu
mitigé de la part d'eads et combattant
de la première heure notamment ceux
qu'on organisait la résistance de ce
tome el boutahiri in dont les images de
dévastation mais aussi de résistance ont
fait le tour du monde on sent qu'une
partie de l'ukraine et l'ouest notamment
et kiev après a pas a fortiori tentent
de tourner une page c'était assez clair
pour ce deuxième séjour on a été quitte
armes est un peu à tourner cette page
d'abord un peu vite et à mettre de côté
un peu les combattants et certainement
en creux c'est sans doute ce qui
explique la la vie c'est la seconde
visite en fait en quelques jours dans
l'est il est tard qu à kharkhiv il ya
quelques jours la dans le don base du
président
hélène ski c'est de montrer de
réaffirmer la présence de l'état alors
qu'on sent qu'il ya une partie de
l'ukraine qui essaient d'ailleurs après
sortie mans de résistance il ya une
résidence extraordinaire et on peut
qu'admirer cette rapidité avec laquelle
les gens se remettent de boue mais ça va
sans doute un peu vite donc pour
répondre à votre question là beaucoup
des héros des grands résistants qui
étaient pour beaucoup ici là la société
civile de cette résistance incroyable
qui a permis de ne pas avoir le siège ou
en tout cas le fait que kiev tombe il ya
deux mois et demi et bien se sortent un
petit peu mis de côté on leur donne pas
tant la parole et il c'est vrai que par
extension ils nous disent on peut
imaginer que nos frères d'armes qui sont
actuellement dans le combat ce sont dans
une situation encore plus compliquée
puisque on est à 600 km de la capitale
on est près de ses zones
russophone on est prêt de la russie
c'est là que se concentre la cette
dernière offensive pour date de l'armée
russe donc on peut comprendre qu'ils
aient un sentiment d'abandon de
difficultés sur le terrain sachant que
c'est absolument terrible enfin la
guerre qui fait rage dans cette partie
orientale du dombass est absolument
inimaginable dans sa dans sa dureté dans
sa dans l'intensité je dirais et dans sa
longévité aussi par rapport au siège de
kiev ou de cartes yves qui ont vite été
mis en déroute adrien de soir c'est à
une guerre d'usure dans laquelle on
entre aujourd'hui
la honte
le quatrième mois de la guerre et comme
l'a très bien rencontrer votre
journaliste c'est une guerre de très
haute intensité on sent que c'est des
combats qui sont très proches de ce
qu'on a connu pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale donc extrêmement violent avec
une artillerie qui bombardent sans cesse
alors effectivement les russes ont
réduit leur front mais l'enfant il est
quand même étendu sur plus de 1000 km
dans l'est de l'ukraine donc c'est une
guerre qui est très difficile à tenir on
observe sur le terrain des petites
offensive mais vraiment on est dans
l'ordre de la conquête des villages de
ferme c'est vraiment plus du tout le
premier mois où on a été des raids
blindés sur sur 200 300 kilomètres avec
effectivement une résistance locale qui
pouvaient saisir et qui hélas vous
frappez des convois qui était arrêtée là
on a une offensive qui est plus
méthodique qui est plus lente aussi un
peu comme un rouleau compresseur
et donc c'est village après village
après des lourds bombardements
d'artillerie que l'armée ukrainienne
progressivement recul dans cette
mâchoire qui se referme du dombass et
notamment à celles airaudo nièce lille
qui est un peu isolée au nord de
l'arrière du dos net tandis que les
forces russes au sud et au nord avancent
vers verse l'audience
voilà ce qui ce que je pourrais garder
sur des guerres d'usure donc les pays
occidentaux en tout cas on le sait
fournissent maintenant des équipements
offensif lourd sergueï lavrov a mis en
garde
elle les pays occidentaux justement
contre les livraisons à kiev d'armes
allons porter on écoute le chef de la
diplomatie russe
tim dowling brunes ou plus vous
fournissez des armes à longue portée au
bout du drop vigueur plus nous
repousserons loin de notre territoire
les lignes depuis lesquelles les néo
nazis dans l'union et aux menaces et la
fédération de russie
jean de gliniasty pourquoi une telle
mise en garde de la part de lavrov et
d'ailleurs de poutine aussi ce week-end
parce qu'effectivement les missiles à
longue portée sont un missile qui
peuvent atteindre la russie et que à ce
moment là à partir de mon le territoire
russe est atteint on est vraiment
on a passé en est en train de passer on
est sur la ligne de crête de l'aco
belligérance si des missiles américains
touche le belgorod ou rostov sur le don
et donc les russes dit simplement que
ils iront attaquer
les endroits enfin c'est ça ce j'imagine
ce qu'ils veulent dire attaquer les
endroits d'où arrivent ces missiles ce
qui veut dire aussi peut-être tout près
de la frontière de pays membres de
l'otan il ya toujours un risque de
contagion horizontale comme on peut le
dire hier au delà justement de l'ukraine
jeu j'ai tendance à penser que non on a
vu que les américains eux-mêmes
écarté l'hypothèse de frappes sur le
territoire russe ils ont dit que leur
but n'était pas de renverser le pouvoir
russe donc chacun essaye de rester en
deçà de la cote belligérance mais il
n'en reste pas moins que c'est une mise
en garde est pour l'instant compte tenu
du fait que les missiles imart ont une
portée de 70 km tirées des alentours de
kerchove il rentre sur le territoire
russe donc il ya aussi un élément de
sagesse dans la du côté ukrainien que
les américains ont sans doute négocier
avant de livrer leurs missiles anastasia
chapeau chinois comment elle agit style
les ukrainiens quand ils entendent ce
type de mises en garde de la part de
poutine je pense que les ukrainiens ils
sont un peu les habitudes de ce stade de
ces de ce genre de discours déjà parce
que il ya une grande conscience qui
percute toutes les sociétés civiles qui
est vraiment qu'elle bloque tout le pays
qui comme beaucoup beaucoup danger et
même des gens des activistes et moi ce
jour selon l'opep la majorité est
vraiment plus de 90 % de personnes parce
qu'il ya plus de travail donc les gens
se sont mis à volontariat et donc tout
le monde
est juste et vous dansez dental les gens
sont habitués à cette à ses discours et
ils ne l ont pas peur parce que il veut
le plus d'armes et n'ont pas peur parce
que ils savent que ils voient ils savent
qu'ils ont bombardé tous les jours il
n'y a pas de changement radical dans les
mots de haies de drogue ou de poutine
pour eux parce qu'ils ont déjà bombardé
ils ont déjà leur frère leur père ou
leur a un mari qui sont qui sont en
train de mourir qui sont morts au front
est ils sont déjà dans les situations de
la guerre ils savent que c'est
maintenant ou jamais qu'il peuvent
défendre leur territoire leur liberté
pour ne pas devenir la russie ou d'alex
de russie ou pour ne pas devenir ses
études us ou de la poésie où la
transnistrie c'est ça ils sont très très
bien conscient de ça et donc c'est fait
pas peur c'est fait plus tôt peut-être
même remonter un peu la résistance aussi
c'est une réaction ça fait remonter
parce que la résistance or ce qu'ils
entendent ce type de commentaires
offensif du côté de vladimir poutine oui
mais en creux ça aussi ça ramène à la le
paradigme aujourd'hui qui est dans la
tête de tous les ukrainiens et qui nous
interrogent nous quand on est sur le
terrain en tant que français c'est que
oui les américains sont assez
volontaires pour nous aider il ya
beaucoup de dizaines de milliards de
dollars qui sont débloqués mais quid de
du des français et quid des déclarations
du président emmanuel macron quotidien
donc c'est un vrai problème mais je
crois que si mais quand même des canons
caesar qui ont été envoyés par l'avion
effectivement mais c'est jamais assez en
ce qui concerne la france puisqu'il ya
la question mais on parlera certainement
de la fameuse médiation ce qui est ce
qui est décrit comme un tango un peu
néfastes de la porte donnant dans la
tête des ukrainiens mais il y a eu la
contre-offensive sur sur cassure kiev
sûr car qui va ensuite et beaucoup de ce
que disent et notre interlocuteur de
contre-offensive c'était la nouvelle
tactique crânienne ces dernières
semaines de contre-offensive sur la
frontière russe donc dans l'est cd rom
nord du dombass la contremarche
iranienne a déjà commencé mais là quand
cela dans le donnant le blaze de kharkiv
qui a été assez effectif puisque alors
on est à 30 km de la frontière russe
dans le donbass c'est pas le cas parce
qu'il ya une concentration plus
importante des russes c'est pour ça que
je disais pour finir que les ukrainiens
attendent veulent qu'un mot c'est que
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale ne tergiverse pas mais
s'engage par la voix je dirais d'envoi
très précis un de canon de moyens
offensifs dont ils manquent cruellement
dans le dans le dos non base quelles que
soient les envois qui puisse y avoir des
nations amies alors la bulgarie la
macédoine du nord et monténégro en tout
cas se sont engagés à leur manière
aujourd'hui puisqu'ils ont empêché à
sergueï lavrov à d'aller en serbie ce
matin puisque l on nous enfermer ces
trois pays bas espace aérien à l'avion
du chef de la diplomatie russe réaction
de sergueï lavrov
bien sûr l'inconcevable ses produits
et je comprends l'intérêt que vous
portez à notre opinion face à ces
mesures scandaleuses
c'est la privation du droit d'un état
souverain de mener sa politique
étrangère
aujourd'hui à 6,3 pays en pleine
d'europe centrale qui est monténégro
macédoine du nord et bulgarie qui
finalement est bien sont du côté des
ukrainiens bah ils ont appliqué les
sanctions européennes puisque l'avoir
fait sur la liste des sanctions je dois
dire que pour ma part j'ai pas trouvé
que c'était une mesure très heureuse
c'est à dire que ça veut dire que en
fait on exclut toute capacité de
négociation alors peut-être qu'on pourra
éventuellement négocier des exemptions
s'il doit venir à paris ou à berlin mais
est donc ces pays là on appliquer la
discipline européenne
mais m des sanctions sur le chef d'état
le ministre des affaires étrangères sur
les négociations futures ou soit on sera
obligé de changer d'avis soit ça veut
dire que l'on voit pas de perspective de
négociation
anastasia myskina je pense que c'est la
deuxième option qu'il ne va pas de
perspective de négociation mais même pu
lire en bulgarie il faut le dire qu'ils
viennent d'être coupé du gaz russe par
la russie je pense que pour rester en
surprise et ils n'ont pas apprécié et
donc celle auront peut-être une des
réponses qui peuvent donner et
deuxièmement on sait qu'il est que même
la préhension surtout dans tous les pays
qui sont le long de la frontière de
l'ukraine de la presse que ce que où
justement vladimir poutine va frapper la
prochaine fois et où est donc ce sûr
c'est sur ces mots de mr la pauvre eux
pour eux c'est l'appréhension de ces
mots et c'est pour ça qu'il va pas je
pense absolument vrai bien des
perspectives de négociations avec eux
par contre ils ont peur que 1 visite
comme une visite comme ça peut encore
gagner des pays comme la serbie et donc
il ya un allié crb tout de même donc il
ya un allié serbe qui reste proche
exactement des rues et donc aider les
russes à diviser l'union européenne dans
les négociations et dans tout ce
processus de justement là l'unisson de
l'occident cyril c'est aussi une guerre
des mots on voit une gare de
communication ça fait partie de cette
guerre d'usure anastasia myskina parlait
justement de ces mots vous le sentez
quand vous allez sur le lien d'ailleurs
et c'est à dire le grand changement avec
le but de la guerre on avait passé
beaucoup de temps justement dans l'est
dans les faubourgs de kiev avec les
combattants ou là en fait même larmes
fin l'armée ukrainienne laisser passer
il n'y avait aucune tentative de
contrôler la dent le blast 2 karkhiv et
on peut le comprendre mais on est plus
tendue on n'est plus dans la tentative
de contrôle de l'information et ça on le
voit et en même temps c'est de bonne
guerre je dirais sans jeu de mots mais
on est réellement dans une guerre
informationnelle des deux côtés et du
côté ukrainien par exemple aucun chiffre
tangibles sur les pertes ça c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on communique en temps de
guerre parce qu'on va pas démoraliser
les gens on lance des procès pour crimes
de guerre effectivement mais on sent
bien que ça va un peu trop vite ou alors
en tout cas c'est très borné mais on est
vraiment rentré comme il ya comme une
comme une symétrie dans une guerre de
propagande qui est outrageusement lancé
par moscou on le sait on l'a vu
d'ailleurs avec un exemple qui nous
touche puisque la l'assassinât notre
confrère la semaine dernière l'agent
stas directement pointe du doigt qu'il
s'agit pas du tout un journaliste de bfm
mais d'un mercenaire qui livré des armes
donc on est dans une symétrie de
propagande sachant qu évidemment du côté
ukrainien on peut le comprendre mais il
ya une opacité importante c'est vrai que
c'est très compliqué de pénétrer dans le
donbass par exemple d'aller au contact
des soldats ce qui n'était pas du tout
le cas dans les premiers combats de
résistance autour de kiev adrien de soi
vous rejoignez ce que vient de dire
cyril payen on ne sait pas par exemple
quels sont les victimes de part et
d'autre ont manifestement un général
russe a été tué par les ukrainiens tout
récemment dans le donbass mais ça c'est
aussi selon les ukrainiens donc c'est
difficile de savoir
oui mais enfin ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'armée russe souffre elle communique un
petit peu sur sur ces morts mais
évidemment elle diminué nord c'est
perdre c'est un peu le jeu ce que les
américains appellent ça y sommes tous
que nous on appelle la propagande et là
dessus d'ailleurs les ukrainiens ont un
petit avantage parce que leur président
dénonce qui opère une propagande assez
assez efficace qu'un peu penser à
clemenceau qui disait pendant la
première guerre mondiale mon programme
c'est de faire la guerre je fais la
guerre jeu la guerre et je fais la
guerre il est tout le temps en treillis
on a l'impression que c'est quasiment un
soldat c'est plus vraiment un président
et donc c'est ça ça porte ses fruits on
l'a vu là dans votre reportage en début
d'émission maintenant il sort de kiev il
se déplace il pas sur les il va au front
pour redonner pour de redonner la de
l'espoir alors que côté russe on à
vladimir poutine qui est quand même plus
distant qui ne veut pas engager jalili à
l'ensemble de la nation dans ce combat
les tuent au contraire minor dit qu'il
s'agit d'une opération spéciale qui
réservait à l'armée mais qui ne concerne
finalement pas l'ensemble de la russie
et d'ailleurs il ne se déclare pas en
guerre alors que pour l'ukraine il
s'agit d'un combat
sur wii anastasia chapeau jusque là
j'imagine que vous voulez réagir à ce
que vient de dire adrien dehors
propagande d'un côté propagande de
l'autre on pour pas grande rue c'est
plutôt maquillage côté ukrainien comme
on vous planifiez pense que quand on est
là face à une guerre conventionnelle qui
est combattu dans une échelle massive
avec des armes conventionnelles qui nous
rappelle toutes les références qu'on
peut on peut en penser nous réfère
toujours à la deuxième guerre mondiale
pour moi c'est vraiment c'est je sais
pas comment réagir car dans la
propagande d'un côté par le programme
d'un autre c'est sûr qu'ils allaient
guerre informatique qui va de deux côtés
mais on ne peut pas nommer les photos ou
les images de nombreuses violences oudéa
ou des cimetières hamas at on n'a pas
nommées ça la propagande de kosovo
pendant les guerres des balkans par
exemple on n'a pas mis en doute sur les
images des nombreuses de nombreuses
personnes ou des villes détruites donc
pour moi c'est la guerre de
l'information dans le sens que et il y a
effectivement tout ce qui est évoqué à
céret tout à l'heure donc il ya les
chiffres trappe pour l'impôt pour les
réseaux militaires etc ces juges du
contrôle en fait c'est la propagande est
exactement mais même âge je peux pas
nommer sur le partage d'informations qui
est fait par les ukrainiens qui est bien
de sélectif parce qu'il ya bien tout et
rien de type de logique mais cette
nouvelle information qu'on peut vérifier
si vous êtes face à un flux massif des
réfugiés ou craignant aujourd'hui en
france vous pouvez vérifier cette
information avec chaque réfugié et il y
as plan qui arrive de mario paul ii mais
l'étau paul de severodonetsk de tout ce
que vous vous pouvez leur demander ce
qu'ils ont vu à vers l'or avec leurs
yeux et ce qu'ils ont vécu et vous serez
tous que c'est sommes pas des matchs des
images qui sont faux par contre en
russie la propagande à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui sur le canal numéro un
est la chaîne numéro 1 télévision russe
il y à des experts militaires qui osent
de parler et de nommay des fautes
militaires portées par le commandement
militaire russe dans un life quand il
s'est vraiment dans l'air et ça c'est
sûr le télé chaîne télévisa numéro 1 en
deuxième exemple que je vous donnais
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux les
buteurs et les influenceurs militaires
les critiques il qu'ils ont donc le
following de entre 400 milles et 2
millions ils portent si maintenant les
critiques sur leur chaîne de télé du
gouvernement russe à cause des dettes de
la propagande qui devient complètement à
diverger avec les réalités sur le
terrain en tout en condamnant basse on
parle de plus en plus de crimes de
guerre kiev qui a annoncé que c'est
justice enquêtait sur quelques 13000
crimes de guerre russes présumés la
justice ukrainienne a rendu déjà trois
décisions un soldat russe a été condamné
à la perpétuité
deux autres soldats ont été condamnés
chacun à 11 ans et demi de prison en
ukraine et la procureur a par ailleurs
annoncé l'ouverture de la première
affaire concernant un viol commis par
des militaires russes cyril alors vous
revenez vous d'ukraine vous avez passé à
peu près une dizaine de jours justement
abuja et dans d'autres villes dans
lesquelles effectivement ces enquêtes
sont mises en place le viol comme arme
de guerre c'est aussi cela la guerre
d'usure en ukraine et c'est en tout cas
ce qui explique aussi pourquoi une
grande majorité d'ukrainiens nous disent
pourquoi votre président par le t-il
encore à vladimir poutine cela dit
mi-août in qui a envoyé ces barbares je
pèse mes mots c'est à dire d une armée
d'occupation qui dans les endroits où
nous on a travaillé c'est à dire dans
l'oblast de quartier v puis dans toute
la région qui jusqu'à la frontière
biélorusse dans le blast de kiev
effectivement c'est assez assez
confondant de d'imaginer une telle un
sentier d'intensité de barbarie donc
évidemment des centaines de viols de
femmes mais d'hommes si des disparitions
d'enfants dont on nous dit qu'ils
étaient emmenés comme trophées dont on a
perdu la trace est sur place même
constaté disait à bordeaux en quarts
mais absolument c'est assez consternant
d'imaginer que en 2022 on puisse alors
évidemment il ya eu des mots des
endroits je pense notamment dans le base
de kharkiv près de la frontière russe ou
c'étaient des débordements liés aux à la
nar cotisations à la drogue ou à
l'alcool de deux soldats qui étaient mal
j'irai mal formés mais ils ont été dures
exécuté pour partent pour certains par
des officiers russes eux-mêmes mais dans
la grande majorité je pense je pense
notamment à ces bataillons qui venait de
l'extrême orient russe qui ont occupé le
blast 2 de kiev pendant un mois et demi
les combattants tchétchènes aussi pour
les témoins qui étaient encore là c'est
en fait des babouchkas des vieilles
dames qui restaient dans les villages
les le constat est accablant odieux
affreux et si vous voulez c'est ça aussi
cette guerre de communication ces
médiations l'internalisation de ce
conflit on nous dit ne parle et non plus
un homme qui envoie ses troupes
commettent des actes aussi barbares et
qui sont oubliés c'est entre 13 et 15
mille selon la procureure craignait
d'aujourd'hui mais ça sera bien au delà
et le drame c'est qu'il y avait les
endroits qui avait été occupé dans la
région de kiev les endroits qui ont été
libérés un peu plus les plus récemment
c'est à dire à kharkiv mais il faut
imaginer ce qui se passe actuellement
dans les zones occupées dans le donbass
notamment en pleine guerre c'est un bon
moment on parle ces choses c'est à dire
ces viols ces exécutions ces crimes de
guerre qui confine pour certains
j'aurais vraiment je serais tenté de le
penser aussi au génocide et bien ont
lieu actuellement c'est pour ça qu'une
forme d'indignation national chez les
ukrainiens pour enfin en fait pour
dénoncer toute forme de tentatives de
médiation avec l'adie maire peut-il
aujourd'hui jean de gliniasty
effectivement on va revenir sur le fait
que emmanuel macron il l'a redit
d'ailleurs dans une interview ce
week-end il ne faut pas humilier poutine
c'est ce qu'a dit le président français
il avait déjà dit la réaction de kiev
bien sûr ne s'est pas fait attendre les
appels à ne pas humilier la russie ne
peuvent qu humilier la france est en
tout cas la manière dont a réagi et demi
trop cool et bat le chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne vous jean de
gliniasty lorsque vous entendez ces
rites païens dire que c'est une
craignant ne comprennent pas que la
france veuille discuter avec la russie
qu'est ce que vous répondez c'est de la
diplomatie faut le faire je répondrai
que en fait même si les agendas les
agendas sont convergent les états unis
l'ukraine et l'europe en tout cas la
france et l'allemagne et l'italie n'ont
pas exactement le même agenda sont
convergents les ukrainiens
veulent se battre le dos au mur pour
leur survie
résiste et veulent le maximum d'armement
le maximum de soutien de 2 à tous égards
et refuse de négocier pour l'instant
tant qu'ils n'auront pas à récupérer
leurs frontières les américains veulent
user
le la puissance russe ils l'ont dit eux
mêmes et les européens eux ils veulent
en tout cas ceux qui sont responsables
si j'ose dire qu'ils ont des
responsabilités continental et qui
souhaitent avoir une politique étrangère
européenne eh bien ils veulent une
stabilité du continent c'est pour ça
qu'ils réservent la possibilité d'une
négociation où il jouerait un rôle
évidemment s'il joue un rôle c'est
normal qu'ils disent qu'il ne faut pas
humilier la russie les américains
peuvent se permettre d' humilier la
russie ça n'a pas d'importance parce que
les les russes négocierons avec les
américains de toutes façons pour le pont
les français les allemands c'est plus
délicat et donc si on veut jouer un rôle
comme on a essayé de le jouer avec le
groupe de minsk fin le désaccord de
minsk si on ne veux pas insulter
l'avenir et bien effectivement il ne
faut pas humilier les chapeaux chics et
là c'est ce que dit emmanuel macron si
on ne veux pas insulter l'avenir il faut
faire attention le traité de versailles
c'est aussi les leçons de l'histoire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce qu
effectivement il ya une fenêtre
d'opportunité pour des négociations
aujourd'hui je suis d'accord avec
monsieur messti c'est dans le fait qu il
riait les différences d'âge en table par
contre là où je sais tu pas d'accord
c'est que
c'est que la france ou l'allemagne
pourront avec cette attitude se
positionner en tant que négociateur dans
le futur et pourquoi j'y pense parce que
déjà dans le passé par le passé soit en
géorgie pas malin guerre en géorgie et
le déplacement de nicolas sarkozy des
dents pour créer pour que les français
aient l'impression de son activité
diplomatique mais qui est toujours rêvé
après que les décisions soient déjà fait
il ya des bouquins sur la question déjà
écrit dessus donc là c'est tout juste
une illusion que décolla sarkozy a fait
quelque chose mais avait arrêté c'était
que les russes nous pas besoin ni des
français ni d helmand pour négocier avec
les américains et pour les russes ce qui
ce que vladimir poutine a dit à
plusieurs reprises et
cessons c'est une guerre avec les états
unis c'est une guerre avec le temps si
vous voulez mais c'est les états unis
qui représentent le temps pour le russe
ne sais pas olaf scholz nîmes agnel
macron qui sont pris à temps que ego
parler du maire peut-il donc dans cette
hausse atteint qui dieu dire cela
attitude elle va juste créé recréer ces
serres pourrait créer ces lotos illusion
à cette puissance diplomatique qui
n'existent pas vraiment parce que les
russes ils n'ont pas négocié avec les
france je conduisais lyon je comprends
tout à fait que pour l'ukraine il n'y a
que les etats-unis qui comptent mais
nous nous sommes européens ne sommes pas
eu craignant défendons l'ukraine nous
soutenons l'ukraine mais nous espérons
avoir une politique européenne une
politique étrangère à une politique de
défense donc ça implique des jugements
un peu différent sur ce que sarkozy a
fait en géorgie les avis diffèrent moi
j'ai entendu un officiel russe dire
quand j'étais ambassadeur à moscou
vous savez sarkozy nous a sorti une
sacrée épine du pied parce qu'il nous a
évité de prendre un tube il ici et ça
nous aurait brouillé avec le poste
jeunes
la géorgie pendant 100 ans donc c'est
facile de dire de néantiser les efforts
de la diplomatie européenne ont été
uniquement sur les états unis mais
l'ukraine est un pays européen et elle
aura besoin de l'europe adrien décevant
vous pouvez réagir peut-être justement
sur ces tentatives sur le fait qu
emmanuel macron disent qu'il ne faut pas
humilier vladimir poutine
weedon moi je suis assez d'accord avec
ce qu'a dit l'ambassadeur de france de
gymnastique c'est à dire que si si la
france veut jouer un rôle si elle veut
comme elle l'a fait effectivement lors
du désaccord de ministres 2014-2015
pouvoir stopper la guerre négocier un
cessez-le-feu faire en sorte que les
armées puissent se retirer la ligne
d'offres etc il faut il faut pouvoir
discuter et ils les américains ont beau
jeu finalement de 2 2 pouces et les
ukrainiens à la guerre à la reconquête
maxi maximale et donc le risque c'est
quand même que de la force finalement
c'est les ukrainiens le plus possible
l'ukraine finissent par s'effondrer
c'est à dire que ce pays souffre quand
même depuis 2014 il s'est
considérablement affaiblie
économiquement la population diminue
démographiquement là elle est sous
embargo commercial chat c'est à dire que
la mer noire mais bloquée elle et elle
est occupée à 25% donc on nous c'est
facile vu des états unis de l'irb à les
hydrater vous vous donne des armes et de
l'argent mais à un moment donné si vous
voulez il faut un petit peu penser
effectivement l équilibre européen et à
la paix paraît assez évident alors cyril
payen peut-être qu'en disent les
ukrainiens qu'ils entendent messieurs
moi je suis tout à fait convaincu c'est
très rationnel de d'entendre ce le
problème c'est quand on sait on est sur
le terrain il est vrai que l'on est
c'est très compliqué
si vous voulez d'expliquer ça à des
ukrainiens qui voit les américains il y
as lilly a longtemps bourg battant en
montrant et d'ailleurs on sait bien et
j'étais en afghanistan ont certainement
pour faire oublier un petit peu d
d'autres débâcle m'équipe il faut se
méfier aussi de quand les américains
s'en mêle mais ça c'est on lit
l'histoire jugera mais c'est un autre
débat mais il est très compliqué
de rationaliser sur un tel débat
aujourd'hui quand le pays il ya eu un
agresseur et agressé points et c'est ça
qui est extrêmement compliqué on est un
peu dans une dans une hystérisation du
débat et on peut le comprendre
parfaitement donc voilà pourquoi on
reprocher à monsieur macron d'abord de
ne pas venir et
le président la république aille à kiev
je ne suis pas dans le secret mais ça
fait très longtemps qu'on se marre de
cette rumeur sans doute avant la fin de
la présidence européenne le 30 juin mais
rien n'est confirmé et là en voyant son
bien
qui est allé à kiev mais il souhaite
encore les ukrainiens qui lie à
déplacement des macros à kiev il est
instamment ils ont besoin de voir
monsieur mâcon j'en ai dit ah si vous
devez nous quitter c'est parce que
malheureusement vous devez nous quittés
bons amis ou encore peut-être sur cette
problématique je pense que le président
macron il ira
en ukraine quand tu auras un élément
nouveau qui apparaîtra il va pas y aller
simplement pour annoncer quatre canons
caesar supplémentaires donc il faudra un
développement diplomatique ou
géopolitique nouveau pour qu'ils
puissent va jouer le rôle qu'il a
toujours essayé de faire avec des succès
inégaux mais certains succès
contrairement à ce qu'on dit et donc
quand tu auras une occasion mais je le
redis encore une fois ce qu'on cherche
c'est créer une politique européenne de
défense européenne l'ukraine a sa place
en europe quelle qu'elle soit et donc il
faudra bien un moment que les européens
se mêle de définir leur propre destin
étant entendu que les ukrainiens c'est à
eux de décider du compromis qu'ils
voudront ou non passer ça c'est clair
oui il faudra trouver leur place après
vous pouvez écouter à très bientôt vous
devez vous départir adasea chapeau china
est ce que c'est le moment justement
quand on écoute cyril sur le terrain
évidemment c'est difficile de recevoir
ce type de message est ce que les
ukrainiens aujourd'hui son prêt à des
négociations est ce que les russes de
leur côté sont prêts à des négociations
parce que les négociations ça se fait à
deux je pense que la question le plus
important de cette question que vous
posez la deuxième question est ce que
les russes ils sont prêts à négociation
et ce qu'on voit sur le terrain c'est
l'avancé mais les terres les comblerait
les reconduire concentration de l'armée
russe dans les endroits l'avancement le
de continuation des crimes de guerre
donc dont justement monsieur payet ne
vient de parler tout à l'heure ça ne
signifie pas du tout ça ne montre pas du
tout une volonté quelconque de négocier
en plus il ya plusieurs exemples de
mauvaise foi dans les négociations sur
tout ce qui concernait les cauris
d'euros monétaire qu'on a observé
pendant toute la période de la siège de
marioupol et qui dans les corridors de
personnes donc c'est à dire mon but
c'est que j'ai essayé de sortir qui ont
été réparé dessus donc pour moi la
volonté de cette guerre c'était pas le
cren qui a voulu se faire envahir par la
russie liste et la russie qu'a décidé le
meilleur look rennes et donc pour
arriver un point de négociation il faut
que la personne qui décide de cette
invasion c'est vraiment malheureusement
c'est ni à paris ni à washington que je
décide sept sites en moscou l'invasion
s'est décidé en moscou seulement et que
cette personne
montre des signes de la volonté moi je
vois passer singh a d'ailleurs déjà vous
voyez vous dessine du côté des russes
puisque vous dites qu'il n'y en a pas du
côté des ukrainiens non mais j'en vois
pas non plus du côté russe et
effectivement il faudra il faut parler
fermement avec la russie mais quand
quand le président dit qu'il faut pas
humilier vladimir poutine c'est
justement pour éviter que le conflit ne
s'enlise ou alors qu'il s'élargisse
c'est à dire que il ya un risque aussi
comme de guerre nucléaire qu'il faut
jamais oublier il ya un risque pour les
autres pays de l'europe et quand on dit
il faut pas l'humilier c'est à dire ne
pas le pousser à prendre une décision
irréparable irrémédiable et qui serait
catastrophique pour l'humanité voilà je
pense qu'il ya aussi ce simple
raisonnement vous êtes d'accord et on
est déjà dans le problème c'est qu'on
est déjà dans l'irréparable pour des
millions d'ukrainiens quand on parle et
là je parle pour moi mais quand on passe
quinze jours à travailler sur les ce qui
sera dans l'histoire exquis ce que
l'histoire retiendra certainement les
crimes de guerre en 2022 perpétré par
l'armée russe c'est à dire c'est violent
c'est disparition ces exécutions
arbitraires j'ai travaillé sur le cas
d'un enfant de neuf mois d'un nourrisson
qui a été violée et tuée des maris qui
on était
mis en joue pour qu on viole leur fille
et leur femme devant eux ça dans des
quartiers résidentiels de la de kiev
c'est à dire à abuja c'est la réalité du
terrain donc les réparable la ligne
rouge elle est pour beaucoup dû pour
tous les ukrainiens elle est déjà passé
et que aussi les combattants qui ont un
peu qui sont post traumatisé ce qu'on
résister vaillamment à l'invasion de
trois jours cette opération militaire
sur kiev au début 10 la guerre n'est pas
terminée la guerre sera terminé quand on
goûtera les uns les envahisseurs hors du
pays est il là ça ils ne seront pas
capables de le faire seul donc on est
dans une thématique certainement
irrationnel mais le mot irréparable il
est déjà largement utilisé toute la
société ukrainienne s'est mobilisée il y
à des millions de réfugiés qui sont
partis il y as d'autant de millions de
gens déplacés des familles qui sont
totalement fracturée on est déjà dans
l'irréparable on est déjà dans
l'histoire horrible de ce qui s'est
passé en plus de trois mois et timothy
sneijder d'ailleurs l'historien
américain spécialiste de l'ukraine et de
la première la deuxième guerre mondiale
pardon lui parle d'un génocide anastasia
parce qu'il a ça va rattraper la russie
ça cette histoire de génocide à mon avis
le génocide c'est quelque chose qui est
quoi l'ukraine avec d'autres d'ailleurs
à anciennes républiques de l'union
soviétique ça fait face avec la russie
pendant aussi le période soviétique ce
n'est pas la première fois que le crâne
faire face à ça mais je pense pas que ce
mot mais cette accusation peut rattraper
la russie mais pas du tout parce que
pour que ce soit efficace il faut que
les institutions internationales qui
sont mises en place pour ensuite la
persécution de des crimes de guerre
soient en capacité de
prendre mettre les éléments sur les
personnes et ensuite les mettre devant
la justice ça c'est absolument
impossible sans de l'invasion militaire
de la russie ce qui n'est pas du tout
cela jean todt de personne donc on n'est
pas du tout dans le cas de l'allemagne
après le deuxième guerre mondiale parce
que l'allemagne était occupé par quatre
pouvoir
mondial et la russie c'est juste une
pays agresseur qui est chez soi et chez
paul et russe il n'y a rien qui se passe
tout va bien donc pour moi je vois
aucune raison pourquoi donc toutes ces
institutions qui sont là pour persécuter
en théorie les crimes de guerre il se
montre absolument inefficace parce qu'il
n'y a qu'un moyen de mettre les permet
la justice ukrainienne elle en tout cas
montre légers délits la cité puisqu'elle
elle fait ce qu'il n'a pratiquement
jamais été fait je crois pendant un
conflit elle est en train de juger un
service chargé des soldats russes pour
crimes de guerre là on ne parle pas
encore de génocide mais vous aussi rires
on vous a parlé du génocide sur place
cette question du génocide je n'étais
pas avec les mots les mots techniques
mais si vous voulez quand les paysans à
berger vo raconte comment une jeune
fille de 18 ans a été emmené et que de
toute façon sa famille a été massacrée
ça c'était à kharkiv sont en effet très
précis est d'ailleurs tout ça aide et
documentée par le par la procureure et
sortira un jour c'est documenté aussi
par la police scientifique parce que là
aussi c'est la mondialisation du conflit
c'est que notamment il ya déjà une
vingtaine de français qui sont à bout de
chat à pied d'oeuvre je peux vous dire
que ils nous le disent rohff
mais ce qu'il voit et ce qu'ils ne
détiennent comme fixation 2010 dire
comme preuves comme indice ça relève
beaucoup plus du génocide qu'une qu'une
simple armée qui s'éteint qui s'est
implanté pendant un mois pour planter sa
tente c'est quelque chose qui relève de
encore une fois de l'ira par alger
revient mais également qe2 delà du crime
de guerre c'est en fait c'est de l'abus
absolue de par sa nature sur une
population parce que c'est une
population opprimée c'est la population
qu'on obéisse et ukrainiens et en
l'espèce on pense bien que certaines
unités avaient en dans l'idée qu'on
allait se servir sur les gens parce que
ce n'était pas des gens égaux
à eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire donc là il ya
une volonté en l'espèce génocidaire
évidemment adrien théaux à ce qu'il ya
effectivement une spécificité de l'armée
russe qui serait extrêmement violente on
a commencé à parler d'ailleurs de la
violence d'un certain nombre de soldats
et bien que j'ai l'impression que
l'infanterie l'infanterie russes étaient
essentiellement en tout cas pour celles
qui étaient débarqués constitué de
mercenaires on l'a dit un tchétchène
de sibérie d'autres régions éloignées de
la russie peut être aussi des jeunes
militaires en fait 100 ans sans beaucoup
d'expérience qui étant peu encadré ont
effectivement commis d'atroces crimes de
guerre en ukraine et ça j'allais dire
malheureusement c'est toutes les guerres
sont horribles ans et c'est
catastrophique et celle ci
malheureusement n'a pas dérogé à la
règle alors moi je suis pas qualifié
pour parler de génocide ou pas
c'est un mot qui effectivement est très
dur très lourde qui renvoie à la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais aussi donc
à la shoah au massacre des arméniens par
les turcs etc donc ça c'est typiquement
le mot qui peut effectivement rendre
toute négociation avec la russie et
toute construction d'une paix future
impossible
nastasia s'approche qui ne
pensent que effectivement déjà ça
renvoie absolument tous ces comparaisons
saran va dans le passé le plus proche on
peut dire génocide aaron de rwanda donc
et ensuite qui inquiétait un hommage au
cid ou à tout ce qui était de ce qui
s'est passé à kosovo par exemple il y à
des guerres toutes les garçons se sont
compliquées mais pas toutes les garçons
pareil parce que même pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale les souvenirs
des gens en ukraine de l'occupation
allemande de la libération de l'armée
par l'armée soviétique qui sont
complètement différentes vraiment la
confession elle ment ça s'est plutôt
bien passé du coup pour beaucoup de gens
parce qu'il est vrai que même le
mécaniste orient justement comme timothy
strider fait des parallèles à un
génocide pratiqué justement pendant 39
45 et celui là il ya bien tout de même
des parallèles qui sont faits avec des
situations historiques par des
historiens comme l'i exactement et elle
a hélas pas juste pour dire que l'armée
russe elle a cette réputation de la
cruauté extrême qu'elle a déjà démontré
en afghanistan pendant le deuxième de
deux guerres de tchétchénie et qui
mentent monde et montera en ukraine
c'est pas nouveau et je voudrais pas
juste minimiser ça à des enfants qui
n'ont pas de parents qui se retrouver
dans leurs mains et c'est que même la
remet de 200000 personnes qui se sont
retrouvées en ukraine il ya des gens
entre 18 et 40 ans et maintenant ce
seront des gens de plus de 40 points
aussi avec les dernières lois
donc en russie qui permet de s'inscrire
dans l'armée un professionnel agréé en
plus de 40 ans donc ce sont quand même
des adultes et ils se sont pas tous des
victimes de drogue ni rien du tout mais
c'est celle abus massifs massif de deux
choses et les drogues l'alcool aide mais
déjà juste l'échelle de sa monde
démontre et approuve les mêmes choses
qu'ils ont déjà fait promis par les
mêmes crimes par le passé - demandant de
nouvelles sur leur territoire alors
juste un dernier tour de table autour
justement du titre cette émission on est
dans une guerre d'usure aujourd'hui pour
conclure cyril c'est ce que ce qui
ressort du terrain bah oui absolument
c'est bon ça va être dur et tient les 10
tonnes d'ici là il ya la conscription il
ya le renouvellement des des soldats en
de moscou notamment est ce que ça va
changer la donne c'était soufflement
aussi c'était simplement aussi des
opinions parce que c'est une guerre qui
a été très médiatisée et ça pèse
évidemment dès aujourd'hui on est c'est
la grande différence avec la seconde
guerre mondiale donc un essoufflement de
l'opinion donc un essoufflement de
pression sur les gouvernements qui ont
peut-être plus les coudées franches pour
faire leur diplomatie de leur côté ou
pas c'est difficile ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il faut que quelque chose se
passe parce que quand on voit le taux de
destruction de marioupol quand on voit
le taux de destruction des villes et qui
sont sous à sorrus ça laisse pantois
c'est à dire en fait c'est quelque chose
se passe c'est à dire qu'il y ait
effectivement sur soi c'est la voie la
voie européenne menée par emmanuel
macron c'est à dire conseillers on
essaie d'opérer des médiations mais les
ukrainiens et on les comprend pour
l'instant dix est pas question on gagne
la guerre on est dans les ukrainiens ont
repoussé leur bail se re l'invasion
russe je ne sais pas mais la guerre
d'usure n'est pas bonne évidemment pour
pour les gens je rappelle que du côté
ukrainien on sait que c'est un ratio de
60 à 100 soldats par jour qui tombe
c'est à dire de dans le donbass donc on
est dans des dents des chiffres
colossaux d'ores et déjà on est en
dehors de tout ce qu'on a connue depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale donc ça d'une
manière ou d'une autre il faut que ça
cesse gardien adrien de ça
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on est dans une
deuxième phase de la guerre ou le front
s'est stabilisé on se souvient des
premiers mois où il y avait des grandes
offensives des grands mouvements qui
pourrait s'observer dans un premier
temps l'armée russe qui avancer très
vite et puis ensuite qui si brutalement
retirée avec des crimes de guerre
documenter absolument atroce et puis
maintenant effectivement depuis
maintenant un mois un mois et demi un
front qui s'est stabilisée et guerre qui
c'est
qui est plus lente donc uniquement pour
les opinions les opinions publiques ce
soit un petit peu désintéressé où sont
un peu différentes qu'avant
et il ya un risque effectivement de la
part de l'ukraine mais aussi des russes
est effectivement de balle de laisser
pourrir ce ce de laisser pourrir cette
guerre et de la laisser comme ça à
vivoter dans un rappel à un conflit qui
pourrait se geler progressivement avec
les années un assez large de fos qui n'a
malheureusement je ne pense pas que ce
conflit elle est en train de se geler ce
que les russes ils ont dit à plusieurs
reprises que leur objectif ne se limite
pas à l'est du pays maintenant on va
dire ça par exemple qui est bien au
dessus des bombardements très lourd je
vais pas commencer à ce gel à ce moment
donc les bombardements l'intensification
des bombardements dans certains endroits
c'est beaucoup plus intense que il ya
quelques semaines les prises de
territoire donc avance les deux heures
mais il perd beaucoup de personnes je
vois pas comment ça peut devenir un
conflit gelé pour moi c'est plutôt jusqu
à quel moment est ce que l'armée russe
peut avancer sk kemboi petit effet et
par quels moyens elle ni l'onu ni l'une
de l'autre on est prêt de vraiment vogel
merci beaucoup à la situation que je
crie ma merci beaucoup adria besoin
merci à jean de gliniasty guettait avec
nous qui a dû partir un peu plus tôt
merci cyril cyril payen grand reporter
évidemment on est impatient de voir
votre documentaire sur ce sujet terrible
des viols armes de guerre en ukraine
merci à vous tous nous arriver
[Musique]